hey guys how's it going so I know it's
not Tuesday but happy tech Tuesday it's
actually Friday which is even more
exciting now I'm just making this video
because I wanted to talk to you guys
about the new Instagram update if you've
never used Instagram before Instagram
has basically changed the way people
take photos they've basically forced
everyone to think in the form of a
square so when you're taking your photo
you gotta back up a little bit extra you
gotta take it the right angle because
you want to be able to fit it into a
square but newsflash they now are
allowing you to post those that aren't
in squares if it was one yesterday so
here's my Instagram and when I click it
you will notice guess what this is not a
square it is a full freaking photo and
when I scroll up square Square and DJ
mini Matt let me show you he posted one
yesterday you will see that this one is
in landscape will use that you can post
videos you can post photos and it's
super easy
there's no to make the sizes you click
that little tiny button that you see
right there here's this little video of
mass giving me kisses he's trying to get
my coffee oh he's so freakin precious so
let's get a good thumbnail there we go
all right I'm sorry to ruin the mystery
of my dog but I post the instagrams for
him he's not sure the first time I'm
posting a video so there it is wow this
is pretty neat this is pretty freaking
exciting what I like about this is you
are posting photos and different ratios
but the main Instagram page keeps
everything in squares and I love it
because it looks all uniform and perfect
so I am a big fan so good job Instagram
this is what happens when you try to
post a panorama photo it will only give
you a little portion of it but man I'm
so upset I was hoping that it would fit
the whole entire thing in there because
that would be amazing which tried to be
like more oh that's nice
although I do like Jennison sittin
obvious sit and wait and wish I love
when people put hashtag no filter on
their instagrams and is alive because
here we go a little structure just to
bring out some of the more detail let's
up the brightness a little hashtag no
filter add some saturation and just a
little bit of sharpen just a crisp it up
testing out the new menu in photo size
but do you guys think so as you can see
look at that it's so little
all the sex because it was a pan out if
you guys look right there up at the top
left there's like that little black
thing oh shoot
no that's gonna drive me nuts forever
that's gonna drive me nuts forever go
comment on that Instagram and tell me
it's gonna be ok
is it gonna be ok is it gonna be okay
I'm not sure it's not ok thank you
thanks for watching I want to know what
you guys think about the new sizes on
Instagram I want to show you Maddy I'm
gonna show you my puppy he's sleeping
this little man is my new world he is my
world and we're in love we're best
friends
he's getting big look at his long little
leg ease you were just sleeping
you're like going down mom let me down
it's gonna be Aspen should play guys
he's so he's so sweet he's such a sweet
little man he has to go get shots today
I'm freaking out
I'll see you later make sure you follow
me on Instagram and be sure to follow
madam Instagram as well he is quite the
looker oh the single ladies all the
single ladies
oh hey little man do you two come here
say bye juice a vine Instagram nope okay
hey guys how's it going I'm Justine
welcome back to cooking with Justine
that's me today we're gonna make a red
velvet cake with cheesecake icing